LORNA GIBSON: So
really the way I
set up the lectures
is I write out
notes for myself of
what I want to cover,
and the notes are
pretty detailed.
And in the past I always
just had the notes for me.
And even though they
were reasonably neat
and I could read them, I didn't
hand them out to the students.
But because I've turned my
fall course into an MITx course
and I want to make the lecture
notes available for that,
when I was doing that course for
MITx I made really nice notes.
And a friend of
mine who lectures,
I was asking her how she did it,
and she said she actually goes
and measures the chalkboard,
and she measures the aspect
ratio, how tall to
wide the chalkboard is.
And then she sets up her notes
so that they're the same aspect
ratio, and she plans
out exactly where
she's going to put everything
on the board on her notes.
And so I started doing that.
And when I'm doing the lecture
I put it all on the board,
and I find a lot
of students-- even
though I hand the
notes out now-- they
like to write their own notes.
And I think it helps them
pay attention in class
and helps them kind of
focus on the material.
So another thing I do in
the lectures, when I first
started lecturing and
for a long time I just
focused on the engineering,
you know, on the equations,
this is the derivation,
this is an example,
this is how you use this.
And it was all just about
kind of the engineering
of whatever I was working on.
And I found over
the last few years,
actually in both courses, in the
fall one on mechanical behavior
and in the spring course
on cellular solids,
I look for more interesting
examples and stories, kind
of stories about the
people who discovered
some of the principles
that we talk about.
I tell them stories about
engineering situations that
came up and there was some
interesting thing happened.
And the students love it.
I mean, they really like having
the kind of hard core mechanics
broken up with some
sort of stories.
So I do that a lot more
now than I used to do.
So probably most
lecturers have some kind
of interesting example
or historical thing
that I talk about.
So for instance, when I
teach the fall course,
the mechanical
behavior materials,
one of the first things
we talk about is stress.
So stress is a
force per unit area.
If I take this piece a wood
and I pull on it like this
I'm pulling on it with a
force that goes out like this.
Stress is just that force
divided by that area.
And the unit of stress in the
SI system is called the Pascal.
And it's named
after Blaise Pascal
who's a French mathematician.
And a couple of years ago I
was in France for a conference
and I was in a little town
called Clermont-Ferrand,
which is in the
middle of France.
It's a pretty little town.
And I'm just walking
around one day
kind of seeing the square
and the cathedral and all
this stuff, and I
see there is sign,
there's like Pascal
something or another.
And this was apparently the
site of Blaise Pascal's house.
And right next door
to it is Cafe Pascal.
So of course, I have to take
a photograph of Cafe Pascal.
And in this other course, when
we get to the bit about stress
and I tell them
about the Pascal I
show them the picture
of the Cafe Pascal.
And the other amusing thing
that they kind of get a kick
out of because of Boston, you
know how in Boston there's
the Freedom Trail and
there's a red line
goes around all these
historical sites
all this colonial and
revolutionary stuff
around Boston.
It's kind of cool, all
the tourists to it.
Well in Clermont-Ferrand
there's a Pascal Trail.
And there's little
metal medallions
of the portrait of Blaise
Pascal put in the sidewalk
and you can walk
around Clermont-Ferrand
doing the Pascal Trail.
So I kind of keep an eye
out for stuff like that
and I put that into
the course now,
and I never used to
do that kind of stuff.
I have a picture from
the Library of Congress,
which I went to just
for fun a while ago.
And one of the main buildings is
this old, beautiful historical
building for the
Library of Congress.
And they have a marble staircase
that goes up the middle.
And the staircase has
all these little cherubs.
And there's an
agriculture cherub
and he's holding
a sheaf of wheat.
And there's a wine
cherub and he's holding
a little thing of grapes.
Well, it turns out
there's a mechanics cherub
and he's holding a gear.
So at the end of
the first lecture
I show them the mechanic's
cherub with the gear.
So there's these
cute little things.
So I just keep an eye out
for these cute little things.
And last fall, this past
fall, one of the students
came up at the end of the
first lecture and he said,
I really like art.
And he says, is there going
to be more art in the class?
And I'm like, not usually.
This has kind of exhausted
my art in mechanics.
And I said, but I'll
keep an eye out.
And through the term there
actually were different things
that I saw that had to
do with mechanics and art
I showed the class.
So one of them was at the
Peabody Essex Museum this fall
there's been and display of the
mobile sculptures of Alexander
Calder.
And they also made
these very large,
I think they're called
stabile sculptures, as well.
The big sail at MIT is
one of his sculptures.
And these mobiles are
actually a really nice example
of free body diagrams in
mechanics and balancing
the forces.
So anyway, I got a picture
of one of his mobiles
and I went up to the exhibit.
And when I was at
the exhibit I found
that he did a degree in
mechanical engineering.
He actually was a
mechanical engineer.
And so the students
were very, very tickled
by the sculpture, the fact
that he studied engineering.
So anyway, I look out
for stuff like that.